submarines just got way more important
and the first reason why is because this
just happens to be the most important
island in the world sitting just 100
miles off China's Southeastern Coast
Taiwan is the key to the South China Sea
and the South China Sea is the key to
controlling the indo-pacific China's
leaders consider Taiwan to be a renegade
Province and Xi Jinping is determined to
reunify it by any means necessary more
than 3 000 miles away across the Indian
Ocean another island nation is watching
closely and its government has decided
to actors
submarine deal historic defense deal
between Australia the UK and U.S
Australia said to confirm the purchase
of at least three U.S virginia-class
nuclear-powered attack submarines as
part of the August deal Australia will
acquire nuclear-powered submarines this
is a big deal people are pissed but why
I mean it's not like submarines are new
they've been around since World War one
so why are China's leaders so afraid of
Technology that's more than 100 years
old the answer is that after a
generation of irrelevance submarines are
emerging from beneath the waves and
whoever Masters this technology will
rule the Seas this is the story of the
most potent weapon Humanity has ever
created and how one small startup wants
to change how we use them
let's start with some quick history
there are lots of steps on the road to
Modern submarines so I'll just focus on
the biggest ones the idea of traveling
beneath the surface of the water has
been around for centuries Alexander the
Great is said to have once ventured
below the Waters of the Aegean Sea
inside a glass Barrel Leonardo da Vinci
toyed with the idea of a submersible
vessel in his notebooks but he never
shared his sketches because he was
worried about quote the evil nature of
men who practice assassination at the
bottom of the sea we had to wait until
1620 for the first ship that could be
navigated underwater it was designed for
the English Royal Navy by a Dutchman
named Cornelius drebel the ore-powered
craft had tubes for breathing and could
travel underwater for hours at a time
his final model which could carry 16
passengers was demonstrated to King
James the first in person the king even
took part in a test dive on the River
Thames but despite this the Royal Navy
couldn't see any useful military
applications for drebles design the next
major advance in underwater ship design
came from North America and a young
inventor named David Bushnell he
designed and built a one-man vessel
called the turtle in 1776. the turtle
was a complete novelty that quickly
exhausted the operator inside but it
still contained a number of Firsts a
screw-like ore moved the boat back and
forth in the water pipes circulated air
ballast tanks allowed the craft to
ascend and descend A Primitive torpedo
even gave it some Firepower to attack
enemy ships 1776 was kind of a busy year
for the United States the founding
fathers had just declared their
independence from the British and were
fighting a war to secure their freedom
Bushnell wanted to help in September of
1776 just two months after the
Declaration of Independence the turtle
was sent to New York Harbor to surprise
British ships blockading the city the
turtle's pilot crapped up on the HMS
Asia and tried to attach explosives to
the side of the ship the attempt failed
but by being the first underwater boat
used in Wartime the turtle showed that
underwater boats could have useful
military applications and before long
the world would get a chance to see what
they could do in Wartime there's so much
to say about submarine warfare during
the two World Wars but this
doubt that so we're gonna skip a bunch
of the details most important takeaway
is that the world wars showed every head
of state and Naval Commander that
submarines had arrived as a powerful
weapon during World War One Germany's
U-boats easily sank battleships trade
ships and passenger vessels like the
Lusitania often with just one torpedo
during World War II U-boats operated in
terrifying wolf packs they tracked enemy
ships attacked at night and then
submerged to escape and plan their next
attack the strategy was incredibly
effective the U-boats sank more than 3
000 Allied ships the Allies were
eventually able to counter the threat
and in the final two years of the war
Germany lost more submarines than it
sang but the technology and tactics of
German U-boats transformed everyone's
perceptions of what submarines could do
in the space of less than 50 years
submarines had gone from a curiosity to
an essential asset for any modern Navy
and they were about to go to the next
level the idea for a nuclear-powered
submarine was first proposed by an
America physicist named Ross Gunn Gunn
was working on the Manhattan Project and
believed nuclear energy could be a neat
solution to the technical problems faced
by conventional submarines the diesel
electric submarines that were prevalent
at the time faced three big problems the
first is that diesel engines need oxygen
to work famously there isn't much of
that underwater so conventional
submarines have to surface frequently
secondly the electric battery is in
conventional submarines could only store
a limited amount of energy this meant
that they needed to be depleted and the
engine had to be refueled the third
problem was a direct result of the first
two needing to refuel and resurface
frequently imposed a hard cap on how
stealthy a conventional submarine could
be gun thought nuclear propulsion could
solve these problems he found an
important Ally in a man named Hyman
rickover rickover was a former
Submariner who spent time working at the
Oak Ridge National Laboratory and he
became obsessed with the idea of U.S
Navy ships being powered by nuclear
energy in 1947 he went around several
layers of superior officers straight to
Fleet Admiral Chester Nimitz who was the
chief of Naval operations Nimitz
immediately understood the potential of
nuclear propulsion in submarines from
there things moved quickly rickover
would oversee the developments of the
USS Nautilus which would become the
world's first nuclear-powered submarine
having caught wind of America's nuclear
submarine development the Soviet Union
soon followed the first Soviet
nuclear-powered sub was called the
linensky consumol and it entered service
in 1958. Navy commanders quickly
realized that nuclear-powered Subs could
carry nuclear weapons the world changed
Forever on July 21 1960. the USS George
Washington stationed at the Eastern
range near Cape Canaveral Dove about 60
feet beneath the surface of the water
from its submerged position it fired a
Polaris A1 nuclear ballistic missile the
Polaris with a blast yield more than 16
times greater than both of the bombs
dropped on Japan in the final days of
World War 2 quickly sped to its Target
all hours missiles arrive at Cape
Canaveral for their first test firings
from the nuclear submarine expressly
designed for the job USS George
Washington by 1967 the U.S Navy had a
fleet of 41 nuclear ballistic missile
submarines at its disposal the age of
comprehensive nuclear deterrence at Sea
had arrived progress barely slowed if
anything it accelerated the USS George
Washington was 380 feet long weighed
5400 tons and could carry 16 Polaris
missiles which could each hit a Target
up to 1400 miles away and the U.S Navy's
14 ohio-class nuclear ballistic missile
submarines are even bigger and more
powerful modern nuclear submarines are a
Marvel their range is limited only by
how much food is on board they can dive
as deep as 800 feet below the surface
and they're so silent that you might not
notice one until it bumped into you the
end result is a ship that can fire
devastating nuclear missiles without
being detected and hit a Target on the
other side of the ocean there are also
this incredible Paradox there's a really
common misconception about why countries
build big militaries and advanced
weapons you probably think they do it to
win Wars but they don't not really they
do it so they don't have to fight wars
in the first place I know it sounds
totally backwards but think about it Sam
the leader of a country and I feel like
invading another country I look at my
map of the world and identify two
potential targets country a is run by
pacifists they don't have an army
country B on the other hand has lots of
weapons they have a big army I think
they might even have nuclear weapons
which country am I more likely to invade
if I'm rational I definitely won't
invade country B this is the concept of
deterrence and it underpins geopolitics
today deterrence isn't always about
military strength part of taiwan's
strategy to repel the threat of Chinese
invasion is its huge semiconductor
industry spearheaded by tsnc if China
invades Taiwan it will be crippling an
industry it relies
when it comes to military deterrence
there's nothing better than nuclear
weapons just one can destroy a major
city a handful can destroy an entire
country in a world with nuclear
deterrence no rational leader starts a
war they aren't absolutely certain they
can win except that's not quite true
there is a more effective deterrent than
nuclear weapons and that's nuclear
weapons three ways military commanders
today talk about something called the
nuclear Triad building a nuclear Triad
is how a country can achieve total
nuclear deterrence the three arms of the
nuclear Triad are land-based nuclear
missiles aircraft with nuclear bombs and
submarine-launched nuclear missiles and
the first two have a critical
vulnerability thanks to spy satellites
it's possible to detect nuclear weapons
that are stored on land or kept on
planes but satellites can't see through
the ocean a submarine that can travel in
near silence for years without refueling
could be anywhere if I'm considering
attacking a country I want to destroy
its nuclear weapons so it can't drop
them on my cities but if they have
nuclear Marines I can't ever be certain
so I probably won't attack in the first
place this is nuclear deterrence at work
it's the logic that kept the world safe
during the Cold War just five countries
are known to have achieved the nuclear
Triad the United States China Russia
India and France those countries can
feel their nuclear submarines safe in
the knowledge that even if their land
and air-based nuclear arsenals were
destroyed they could still launch
nuclear missiles from their submarines
deterrence is a vital part of why
submarines are so important but it's
only half the story to fully understand
why submarines are going to define the
next 25 years of geopolitics we need to
talk about great power competition
throughout the modern era the world has
been dominated by large powerful
countries often these countries were
actually Empires that controlled
territory outside of their natural
borders but that's a story for another
day this system wasn't very effective at
producing peace just look at the history
of Europe up until World War II but it
was sort of stable because these compete
leading Empires were big enough and
powerful enough to weather everything
except the biggest crises World War II
and the wave of decolonization changed
that it totally disrupted this world
order Nazi Germany and Imperial Japan
were both destroyed the French and
British exhausted from war gave up their
colonial possessions two big winners
were the United States and the Soviet
Union they were both unquestionably the
two most powerful countries in the world
each had massive militaries and huge
industrial manufacturing bases they were
at the Forefront of scientific and
cultural progress they also had
ideologies that were totally
incompatible with each other so they
competed with each other in every
conceivable domain technology the
military the economy diplomacy even
sport it was all fair game the Cold War
era was what political scientists called
a bipolar world because there were two
major Powers then in the early 1990s the
Soviet Union collapsed with its main
rival gone the U.S was left as the
world's only superpower and all of a
sudden we were living in a unipolar
world that situation persisted even
through 9 11 in the war on terror the
U.S faced threats to its National
Security but they weren't really the
same kinds of threats as during World
War II or the Cold War enemies like Al
Qaeda and the Taliban weren't countries
and they used totally different tactics
and Technology Al-Qaeda didn't have
nukes the used IEDs the Taliban didn't
have migs they used AK-47s and Isis
didn't have submarines they preferred
Toyota hiluxes there's no doubt the war
on terror tested America's standing and
maybe even its power but it was still
the world's only superpower until that
is the rise of China for the first time
in a generation we're living in a world
with two superpowers great power
competition is back today China is
stronger than the Soviet Union ever was
it's caught up to and even overtaken the
United States in some key areas the
people's Liberation Army is the biggest
military force in the world China's Navy
has more ships than Americans and helped
by Industrial Level Espionage and
massive State intervention it's ahead of
the U.S in several critical Technologies
but even this rapid progress isn't
enough for China's leaders Xi Jinping he
is determined to restore China to what
he sees as its rightful place at the top
of the world order and secure the
legitimacy of both the Chinese Communist
party and its own rule one of the
foundations of his strategy is the South
China Sea and he wants total control the
South China Sea is important for a bunch
of reasons it's Central to the global
economy a third of the world's Maritime
shipping goes through the South China
Sea destined for places like China
Vietnam and Indonesia it's rich in
resources there are huge oil and gas
Fields Under the Sea beds and abundant
Fisheries which feed millions of people
in Southeast Asia and it's a platform
for military power if you control the
South China Sea you effectively control
the Indo
strategic and economic importance of the
South China Sea is what's driving
several ongoing disputes about things
ranging from fishing rights to who owns
small Islands pretty much all of these
disputes involve China a lot of the
tension stems from the fact that China
uses a different Maritime border to
demarcate its territory in the South
China Sea it's called the nine dash line
you can see it here on a map the problem
is the nine-dash line overlaps the
economic zones of several other
countries with borders on the South
China Sea Xi Jinping decided that
instead of debating the semantics in
court he'd use Force instead that's why
starting in 2013 China has built seven
artificial islands in the South China
Sea those islands each have military
bases airports Radars and fortifications
photos even show Sports fields and
basketball courts now China says that
these are all legitimate territorial
claims but clearly what it really wants
is to bully countries like the
Philippines and Vietnam into doing what
it wants and they want to send other
countries in the region a stark warning
better do what we want or there might be
consequences China's aggression isn't
limited to the South China Sea either
when Australia called for an independent
inquiry into the origins of covid-19
China's leaders responded with an
unprecedented wave of sanctions and
restrictions on Australian exports this
broke an informal agreement between the
two countries to forge strong economic
ties without interfering in each other's
politics this was a big deal China's
economic Miracle of the 2000s and 2010s
was built with Australian coal and iron
ore Australia's economy has actually
held up quite well to the sanctions but
its leaders decided they wanted greater
protection against Chinese intimidation
enter August like I said the August deal
pissed off a lot of people and I'm not
just talking about Xi Jinping in order
to sign August the Australian government
tore up a contract to buy 12 french-made
submarines there had been some rumble
feelings the project was behind schedule
but no one in Australia really expected
it to be canceled so abruptly Emanuel
macron was Furious here's what he had to
say when he was asked about the behavior
of Australia's prime minister Scott
Morrison I have a lot of respect for
your country I have a lot of respect and
a lot of friendship for you people I do
say when you when we have respect you
have to be too do you think he lied to
you I don't think I know France and
Australia have mostly patched things up
Australia having a new prime minister
helped with that and Emmanuel macron
couldn't really afford to stay mad at
the U.S for long so what does August
actually entail it has three main
pillars the first will see America
Australia and the UK work together much
more closely on the development of
Technologies with military and defense
applications the idea here is to make it
easier to share platforms exchange
knowledge and reduce costs the second
pillar of Oculus will see the three
countries accelerate the development of
hypersonic missiles and Hypersonic
missile defense that's very important
today China leads the world in
Hypersonic missiles and the U.S military
has admitted it does not currently have
an adequate defense against them and
then there's the main event under August
Australia will buy eight nuclear-powered
submarines they'll be based on a British
design but they'll have American
Technology and an American combat system
inside and while Australia Waits For
Those submarines to be built they're
going to buy three U.S virginia-class
submarines in the meantime there's a
bunch of implications for Australia
which will have to create a nuclear
industry from scratch but the main
impact will be on geopolitics August
will draw the three countries much
closer than they've ever been while
completely transforming Australia's
defense capabilities here's what Joe
Biden had to say about it in San Diego
August has one overriding objective
enhance the stability of indo-pacific
amid rapidly shifting Global Dynamics
simply stated we're putting ourselves in
the strongest possible position to
navigate the challenges of today and
tomorrow together the entire 25-minute
press conference was dominated by a word
no one ever said can you guess yeah
that's right China the leaders of the
August member states keep saying August
isn't about countering China but
everyone including China knows that's
the main goal here's what one of China's
most senior diplomats had to say about
August speaking the three countries have
gone further and further down a wrong
and dangerous road for their own selfish
political gains in complete disregard of
the concerns of the International
Community the global times a ccpo
newspaper warned Australia to avoid
provocation or else China would punish
it with no mercy so why is China so
angry about ocus partly this is just the
standard playbook for China especially
when it believes that Western countries
are meddling in its sphere of influence
by the way this idea that big countries
have a sphere of influence and that
inside the sphere they can basically do
whatever they want that's a staple of
great power competition it underpinned
Russia's strategic thinking even after
the collapse of the Soviet Union and
it's one of the reasons that Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine but I think
China's reaction to August also reflects
another emotion doubt by strengthening
Australia's Navy and increasing the U.S
presence in the indo-pacific August
makes it harder for China to achieve its
goal of reshaping the international
order
and the main reason why is because of
our new favorite word when the United
States was fighting terrorists in the
Middle East it didn't need to worry
about deterrence it didn't need the
world's most advanced nuclear submarines
because it wasn't fighting against a
conventional rational enemy it was
fighting militants in caves in the
desert but in a world of great power
competition you need to be able to deter
your enemies you need to be able to
persuade actual countries to become your
allies
and ultimately you need to use every
tool at your disposal to achieve your
strategic goals now there's still one
more major question to answer what does
the future of submarines look like the
best place to begin answering this
question is to look at the other side
the development of anti-submarine
morphing because if modern nuclear
submarines are the most potent weapons
ever made which they probably are then
it makes sense to invest in tools that
can counter them anti-submarine
technology mainly focuses on two areas
detection and tracking neither are easy
but detection is harder since the 1980s
the United States and its allies have
used a network of underwater microphones
called the fixed distributed system or
fds to detect and identify passing Subs
the fds uses microphones that are
Tethered to the sea floor and can block
out ambient noise for now these
listening arrays are the most reliable
way of detecting quiet submarines but as
we all know necessity is the mother of
all invention so there's quite a lot of
work going into this space DARPA the
pentagon's experimental research
division is currently working on an
ocean of things project to quote enable
persistent Maritime situational
awareness over large ocean areas by
deploying thousands of low-cost
intelligent floats that drift as a
distributed sensor Network basically
they're smart buoys plugged into a
network of sensors submarine detection
is being developed in parallel with
technology to track them once they've
been discovered that's the easy part or
at least relatively easy Once you find a
submarine even a nuclear one they're
actually kind of vulnerable by the
standards of modern ships they're pretty
slow and not very maneuverable and
because they're massive strategic value
their big Target back in 2011
researchers at DARPA were exploring the
possibility of building an autonomous
Naval vessel to track enemy submarines
but they quickly ran into a problem they
couldn't figure out what the autonomous
vessel should do after it detected the
enemy sub they couldn't use real life
situations because they were classified
and besides there probably weren't
enough to form form a sufficiently large
data set so instead DARPA got creative
there's a game from 2006 called
Dangerous Waters it's available on Steam
when a reviewer even called it without a
doubt the best Naval submarine Sim I've
ever played DARPA took Dangerous Waters
and modified it so players could control
a ship that followed submarines across
five Missions at the end of each Mission
players were asked if they wanted to
share their gameplay footage darpa's
researchers reviewed the footage to
learn about what worked and what didn't
tactics deemed useful would be
programmed into the software for the
real life ship or used to improve the
ship's design this is pretty crazy but
it gets even crazier because in 2016
five years after asking Gamers to play
that mod DARPA actually unveiled a
prototype of the ship Gamer's help
design it was called the Sea Hunter it's
one of the most promising examples of a
new type of Naval vessel that can track
submarines for months at a time without
a single crew member but there's still a
problem anything above the surface is
vulnerable so what about autonomous
ships that operate underwater or in
other words autonomous submarines and
this is where modern tech startups are
having an impact so why is this
important I've spent the last few months
absolutely obsessed with anderol they're
just a different kind of defense company
their founder Palmer Lucky came to
prominence because he invented the
Oculus VR headset and then he founded
android Because he believes the
old-fashioned approach to defense
procurement isn't delivering enough
Innovation and just recently Andrew
acquired a company called Dive
Technologies I was interested to learn
why Palmer lucky thinks that autonomous
submarines are such a big opportunity so
I asked him submarines are important and
challenging we build robotic submarines
powered by our artificial intelligence
they can dive down to about 6 000 meters
which means that we can go to the bottom
of any part of any ocean that does not
end in trench or crevasse which which is
a big deal they have to be smart enough
to change and alter and perform their
mission without continuous human
guidance and it's one of the few ways
where we can go to places we're not
supposed to be we can listen to people
we can follow people we can interact
with their infrastructure we can make
sure that they're not interacting with
our infrastructure there's so many
things that are critical at the bottom
of the ocean you have the undersea
cables that are linking the entire world
together in terms of information you
have a lot of energy transfer happening
over power cables but also oil and gas
pipelines you have a lot of other
critical National Security capabilities
that are living under sea before it was
acquired by anderol dive's main product
was the dive LD it's a bit smaller than
the Ohio class submarines the US Navy
uses the dive LD is just 20 feet long
but it leverages software in a way that
no submarine has ever before the goal is
to produce these for a fraction of the
cost of existing submarines while
keeping the platform modular so it can
be optimized for different kinds of
missions such as following enemy
submarines seabed mapping or critical
infrastructure monitoring the impression
that I got from talking to some of
Android staff is that dive just fit
really well with their company's
philosophy annual isn't interested in
building better versions of traditional
things they're interested in developing
technologies that allow you to Envision
new approaches to existing problems but
of course just as Technologies like
autonomous submarines help solve old
problems in new ways they also create
new ones that need to be solved late
last year when the Australians were
still debating the merits of August and
the Chinese were still angry about it
anderol signed a 100 million dollar plus
deal with the Australian Navy to produce
three new prototype large autonomous
underwater vehicles but there's a bigger
question as to why Andrew will wound up
in this situation to begin with after
all normally new military technology
would be developed by one of the big
defense primes but sadly those companies
have simply stopped innovating and to
understand why you have to watch this
video next thanks a lot